Alright folks, welcome back, a little bit earlier broadcast today, I had some plans
this evening so I want to get it out of the way.
Alright, so we're looking at obviously a hindsight view of something I pointed to before it happened
so that way you guys got a chance to see what it was like for my private mentorship group.
When I say these things, it's almost like an invitation for some of you to email me
to ask to join in, you can't join in, okay, I'm teaching mentorship on YouTube, okay,
so that way you don't need to reach out to me, okay, it's, I'm teaching right here and
you didn't have to send me any credit card information, you didn't have to set up any
kind of PayPal account, there's nothing to worry about, you either watch it and enjoy
it and get something from it or you never come back and watch it anymore, okay, it's
very simple.
But I'm getting a lot of feedback from the comments and it's been very positive so I
thank you for that, it's very encouraging.
Alright, so we're looking at the e-mini NASDAQ futures contract for the March delivery.
If you remember, I was outlining this imbalance in here, okay, and I gave you the high of
this candle, the low of that candle, which it should be sitting right on that.
So with this imbalance, we traded down to a discount, back up to a premium, again, measure
the high to the low and I'll do that for you now because I know some of you are like, can
you just do it for me?
Alright, so here's 50% of the equilibrium inside this dealing range, high and low.
So we traded from these lows up into a premium, above 50%, below 50% is a discount, up here
we tried to rally up above this high, failed, broke back down below 50%, then created a
gap, okay, so it comes up back into a premium market above 50% and fills in the gap.
I mentioned how this type of retracement can lull traders into likely thinking it's going
to go higher, but we're thinking down here, okay, the liquidity resting below here is
what they're going to attack.
So all of this consolidation just sets up another selling opportunity to run down there
and again, you're welcome to go back and listen to the previous discussions and you'll hear
me basically say that we're going down here.
Alright, so it needs to rebalance this first and it spends three days in that range, notice
that, then it releases a downside, attacks the sell side here and trades into the sell
side liquidity resting below here.
So let's go into a lower time frame hourly chart and ferried out some more information
and details.
Alright, so here is the hourly chart and you can see that high end of the fair value gap
and the low end of the fair value gap, we traded up into that, sold off, consolidated,
sold off once more and you watched me share on the community tab my live trades from yesterday.
It was traded through TD Ameritrade, it was not a demo account, okay.
So I want to go into what I used, what I saw and then obviously I'll show you in the account
where the details were, okay.
Alright, so the market started trading, rallied up, took out a short-term high on Friday,
see that, then started to break down and then overnight I was watching this but I was hoping
that it didn't take out that low before the morning.
I wanted to see it trade up here, take that high out and then consolidate after running
below that short-term low.
I didn't want it to be in a hurry before the New York session in the morning because that
would have set up a nice short up here where I could have taken a run under this low and
then see if I can capture a re-entry which is the entry you'll actually see me do and
then the drop down in here.
Now on Monday it was a bank holiday and trading stops at 1 o'clock in the afternoon on holidays
generally and resumes around 6 o'clock in the afternoon in New York time and when we
stopped here we had already moved aggressively lower and stopped right there so I felt very
strongly that we were going to gap down below it and it gave us the beautiful gap lower
and run immediately but I was looking at the 13.590, 13.586 level real time and I couldn't
get to my screen fast enough to close it out there and I didn't want to put a limit order
in because if it gapped really far down below and started running really lower with a lot
of speed and such I didn't want to limit my profitable exit with having a limit order
in so I just left it open ended and I wanted to see how far I would reach down in there.
By the time I closed the trade it closed me at 13,612.25 so my entry was 13,858.25 the
exit was 13,612.25 that's not a little bit of ticks okay 240 some plus handles so you
take that 240 some times that by four there's your tick value for those that like to keep
counting that. I'm going to drop down into a 15 minute time frame alright so we had that
run on Friday's high here started the breakdown and as you can see we had a little bit of
at 10.30 in the morning 10.33 was the actual fill so it's right in that candle right in
here I'm trading in that candle going short so we're going to go into the details and
look at why that was the case and again you'll see the live account login and the business
okay so just hold on to your horses if that's the attitude you have right now oh you in
the hindsight so we're going to go into a five minute chart start going down into the
details here this is a little bit taller so that way you can appreciate the imbalances
that are being shown alright so we had this rally up which in my mind was acting like
a judas swing in the morning okay so here's 8.30 it starts to run higher so I want to
be in going short at this candle's opening and you can see that well maybe you can't
see it the opening price over here okay here is 8.30's candle right there the opening
at 13.798.5 so I want to be preferably going short something above that price okay so I'm
anticipating further weakness and before I get any further in this one I got several
people probably about half a dozen or so mentioning their confusion with why I mentioned the opening
price at New York at midnight and then the opening price at 8.30 in the morning there's
two reference points being specifically dealt with there if you're looking at the entire
daily range you're going to use the opening price at midnight but if you're going to be
looking at the morning session you're going to be looking at the 8.30 in the morning opening
price okay so hopefully that's made a distinction there don't worry I have a market structured
lesson coming up on Thursday that will further solidify and remove all doubts and concerns
about that okay but for now let's just go through this one so 8.30 in the morning the
opening price I'm bearish I'm thinking we're going to go down below that green level there
that's the old daily low so on this candle here at 8.30 I'm expecting all this being
a fake rally it's something to lull in traders to chase it going higher the retracement people
that don't really understand order blocks they're going to say look at that it's a down
close candle I'm going to buy that and then when it starts to go up like that they feel
wow this is really easy every down close candle after a run up is a bull shoulder block it's
not in here is the real context okay we have an imbalance there and that's what I'm looking
at I'm looking at this imbalance right there so I'm trying to operate inside that range
for a short now I know because of the volatility it can color outside the lines and it's okay
the bodies of the candles are kind of supporting the idea of what I'm looking for but the wicks
I could care less about because I want to get in when it's ideal and I'm going to show
you what that looks like for me at the time so we're going to drop down into a four minute
chart okay so here is that imbalance and fair value gap on the five minute chart but now
it's a little skewed because it takes up two candles to show that range market trades up
and right in that candle that one right there is that's where I'm going short I got in at
1033 okay that was my short dropping down into a three minute chart okay the market
trades up works inside that imbalance and right there 1033 that candle when it's starting
to bump up against the top end of that fair value gap right there as it hits that and
starts to move away I'm in there I'm going short right there the reason why I'm trusting
that and not thinking it's going to go higher is because we have this high here okay and
then we have this high here which highs higher this one or that one obviously this one now
this candles high watch what happens from this high we have a short term swing high
next to it here and then we have one here so this one makes a intermediate term high
so we have a long term intraday on a three minute chart which sounds like an oxymoron
but long term high intermediate term high because this high is lower than that one but we have
a swing high here and here that are lower both being lower than this one then we have
the same context right here we have a high with a lower high on either side of it so
I have market structure behind me showing that this is number one it's a bearish market
because my draw on liquidity is down here it hasn't traded down there yet okay so it's
going to act like a big magnet so all these fluctuations in here without understanding
what I'm showing you it's going to feel like it's just noise it's chop it's not it's actually
telling you exactly what it's going to do so the swing high here is an intermediate
term swing high so I want to be going short real close to this high because it's likely
to break like it does here so at ten thirty three when it hits the upper end of that fair
value gap I have it now at this moment go back one candle we have this high higher high
in the lower high so we have a high with a lower high on either side of it that's a swing
high that is lower than this one that is lower than that one so it's far more than
just oh he's just looking at lower lows lower highs that's what a myopic individual would
come and watch this so like when they see me put a rectangle on the chart they're saying
oh it's supplying demand it's not there's so many more factors involved that it's just
not even in the same vicinity so sparing all that compare and contrast because I've done
a lot of that already on the videos on this YouTube channel the elements of intermediate
term short term highs I learned that from Larry Williams okay that mode of deciphering
market structure he taught that in a video course that I bought back in the early nineties
and it was a video course I mentioned many times in this YouTube channel the future millionaires
confidential trading course something to that effect it was four VHS tapes and when he
talked about market structure it kind of went over my head the first few times listening
to it like I didn't really understand what he was showing until I started literally going
into the charts and saying okay here's a swing high and this is how you learn it okay because
trust me watching this video or watching someone else parrot what I say and then say
wow he did it in five minutes he's teaching it better that's not it's not jealousy me
saying that I'm telling you you have no idea what you're doing you're not even teaching
it correctly and those that believe that are learning it correctly are going out there
and are wrecking themselves what you're looking at is a price chart with a directional bias
okay something that's leading to a draw on liquidity so I've already told you last week
that we were going to go below that green line that's where we were heading so what
you're doing is you're looking at all the swing highs and every time you see a swing
high and a swing high is simply a high that has a lower high candle to the left of it
and a lower high candle to the right of it and then one in the middle that's your swing
high note that okay in the old days when we printed out our charts and such and we had
chart books delivered to us we would get them once a week they would give us the Fridays
closing data and all the daily candles and then until we got our new updated chart book
we had to hand draw in the open high low and close on the charts on the markets that we
were following so whenever we saw a swing high or swing low we would just put a little
ring above it a little circle okay like a little halo and that would be a short-term
high now I would do a double circle or double halo for an intermediate term high and then
three halos for a long-term swing high so that way when I'm looking at price it allows
me to classify the level of high that is forming so it's not just lower low lower
high no you got to look at the nesting effect of the highs and lows and again that concept
I learned from Larry Williams in the early 90s he talks a little bit about it in his
book how I made a million dollar trading commodities last year which I believe is absolutely still
essential reading even though there's a lot of things in that book I think is just fluff
and just like all the moon phases and things I'm not into all that stuff but his chapters
on market structure and his million dollar trading concepts those ideas in that premise
behind it they are still true today and they probably will always be true so if you don't
have that book my recommendation is to get it go and get it where we can I'm not going
to put any kind of affiliate links up so that way you can't think I'm making any money by
showing his his books I just think it's a really good book and at least once a year
I go through and read it just for nostalgia reasons but I've got it pretty much remembered
verbatim but by looking at that relationship of the highs I trusted this because we had
a swing high here already in effect and I know this camel here is not likely to go above
this one because this one didn't go above that one and this one didn't go above that
one not because it's lower lows and lower highs there's much more going on underneath
the surface than just lower lows and lower highs that's just it's cringy when you hear
people talk like that and they try to reduce it down to something like that or it's a support
resistance idea it's just by the floor and sell the ceiling okay or why doesn't ICT look
at this trade over here in this tree because those trades are being referred to in hindsight
by those people that talk like that I'm literally taking live trades I'm taking them I'm executing
on them and I know why I'm doing it I'm not guessing I'm not trying to figure out or deciphering
what it is after I get in trade I know what I'm looking for and I know why I'm waiting for it
that is something that you learn by developing patience and trusting a model the only way you
trust it is to go through back testing look at all these price action moves and start classifying
the swing highs and swing lows I will amplify what I just talked about here on Thursday's lesson
because Thursday's lesson is going to be on market structure okay I'm going to teach a lot
of people out there to think they know market structure they don't really know that much at
all actually but if this is the candle I'm trying to get in it and I execute on with all
the understand this outline there I want to see displacement we get it here now if I didn't take
this trade here I could trade with the return back to this right here why why is that possible
we have a swing high it's broken to the upside this low is taken out here this candle is high
here if it touches that again I can be short there just using the imbalance in the fair value
gap entry technique I'm teaching you so I can go there and get short or I want to get up here as
close as I can to that important high that I've already outlined here so I want to be in that and
wait for that initial move because then when this occurs when you're that high up in the
well the session high so at 830 right there this run up I'm real close to this high by
notice that I'm not waiting for a breakout below that low so I'm getting up in there where it's
an optimal entry I don't need to get the highest high you don't need to get the highest high but
you need to understand why it should be trading away from the levels you're trying to enter at
and that's kind of like what I'm showing you here I'm hinting at a deeper lesson I'll give
you on Thursday but the displacement comes which is what I was waiting for and it gives
you a confirmation when this occurs it's just almost like okay just sit back and just relax
and just let it do its thing now Monday again was a holiday so I knew I had abbreviated session
hours I was going to close at one o'clock so that's right in here and then the next candle
obviously would be one o'clock and it's not trading so I closed but it closed here I had
up one o'clock and then the holiday session closing at 1 p.m. in New York local time and
the low that green level here remember go back to the daily chart at the beginning of the video
and what we were referring to last week the liquidity the sell stops below this green line
that's where it was going to attack okay and it came in and did so it opened up six o'clock
in New York time opened up and slammed down accelerating lower that is the move that you
want to see being short up here and covering down below here once it does that and it runs
into low deep that's it take your profits and move to the sidelines and then wait because you
have a big gap here it's likely to come back and rebalance that and fill it in and it does
and then ultimately trades around that old low and eventually pumps up into the afternoon
consolidates then goes into the early morning afternoon hours right there and I showed how
this set up because after a big move you don't want to trade in the morning session just don't
do it and I purposely go into a demo account to appease that desire to want to trade so I don't
burn the account I don't take the heat off of a nice win and replace it or dampen it by taking a
losing trade in my history in the last 30 years I've been fortunate enough to know how I have
hurt myself those things are the things that I like to mentor with but those are also the lessons
that everybody complains about until they lose money and then they come back to me and they're
like I wish I would have listened so I get it you know everybody has their own interpretation
what they should be doing how they should be learning it but you know I've lived it you're
just now you're learning about it so when I have a nice winning day as you'll see it was a nice
little win I'm not in a hurry to go back in and then you have these days here where it can trip
you up you don't know what's going on you don't know what's likely to occur so I went in and I
traded and used again quote-unquote discount broker leverage to compare and contrast those
fellows out there that like to work in their market replay and paper trade their stuff with
Ninja trader and then you know compare and contrast you know what I'm doing with trading
view so it kind of like scratches an itch and it keeps me out of trouble with a live account
because if you catch a good lick in the marketplace and you had winning trades or you caught a really
nice winning trade that you had to wait for the setup to pan out when that occurs if you're new
you have an impulsive tendency to want to go back in immediately and get that dopamine hit again
like I did something right you know I made money when I was a younger man I did that and I had some
really nice run-ups in the account and then boom I get a really big winning trade all of a sudden I
feel like it wasn't enough because I was solo nobody around me was supporting me I had no support
structure around me none I didn't have a nice saying hey what you do is awesome you know you
don't need to worry about anymore so it was just me saying I had to do more so one of the mental
hurdles you're gonna have to contend with is knowing when enough is enough and when you've
made money real money in a live account you just won't want to rush to get back in there again you
get folks out there that sit on social media say you know you got to push your edge no you don't
want to push your edge because if you keep pushing your edge you're gonna dull it you sharpen it by
knowing when to get in and when to get out and you don't dull your edge okay so when I hear people
talk like that I already know they're not profitable I know they're not profitable because
they're gamblers and they want to sound like they're doing something all the time and they're not and
if they are they're doing it probably unprofitably so this morning after 930 again what's the bias
bearish that has not changed even though we had this run up it hasn't changed so at 930
equities open after consolidation it runs up creates a high and then runs up again takes out
the high that right there is your run on stops wait to see if it wants to break down it does
so we're gonna look at that and refer back to the video I just put a little short video up this
morning and outlined the whole business here I don't want to do it here because this is rehashing
what I already showed in a very short one minute or so video but ultimately right in here we have
a nice little selling opportunity and you can attack the fair value gap in here between the low
and the high right there it would be and if you want to trade with the longer term bias you can
attack this sell side liquidity resting below here and here because they're relative equal loads and
then you would have got a nice fill there as well so I teach in a manner that allows my students
to pick number one the style of trader they want to be they want to be a day trader they want to
be a scalper they want to be intraday swing trader if they want to be a short-term trader
where you're holding over to you know overnight or if you want to be a daily chart swing trader
or four-hour chart swing trader we are holding you for a week or more or if you want to do a
position trader which to me is I don't have I don't have that mentality to do that I have too
many things that show up on a chart that make me change my mind all the time so I have a lot more
opportunities because I think short-term and I excel in short-term it that does not mean that
that is not a profitable way of trading when it's position trading it says I don't match that
personality wise so I like to excel where I'm strongest and it's in intraday trading and I can
run the account pretty quick with velocity I can get in get short-term moves in this parlay them
up real quick which is kind of like what I was demonstrating you know facetiously this morning
with the women in video filming my news at the quant so we're looking at the likelihood of
potentially going back down below that level again if it does it'll probably start to accelerate
I like 13,300 if we get you know in a roll going lower I like that one maybe even if we get really
excited you can trade down into 12,000 okay 12,000 850 12,000 875 in that area so just something to
think about I'm not suggesting you should take a trade in it or not but just thinking out loud
this lesson obviously it was a little bit fast and loose and then we'll be a lot more structured
on the market structured lesson on Thursday hopefully you found this one insightful and
I'm going to show you again this was a trade actually took with a live account
all right so I'm going to log into my TD Ameritrade account
and I'll show you a result of a trade I took yesterday I have not taken any live trades today
again this is just to show real executions are being done I like to teach with the demo
but just the answer to folks they're just really hardline critics or just want to know
can I push the button push the button I see you all right so here is the business
for the last six days trading and again this account is just to show what I believe a student
could do now right away look at this right here that's this is not a losing trade it looks like
negative twenty seven hundred dollars and fifty five twenty seven fifty five what that is is an
adjustment by the broker because at the time of settlement when I closed the trade it showed that
I was up four thousand nine hundred twenty dollars and then because of their accounting
they were just showing that they were reflecting a gain of seven thousand six hundred seventy five
dollars which is not a actual realized result for me it was them doing their administrative side
it's a broker thing trust me I cannot do anything to make that happen it's not me doing some funny
money business okay anybody that trades with live funds they've probably seen this happen in their
own account so over here you can see the execution just today at a scratch where I got in a little
too early I was a little ambitious and then the second one I wasn't sure if it was going to go
higher or lower and just to appease my curiosity I threw a short end just to see what we get
snapped against me a little bit not not much but still enough to get my attention and I knew what
I was looking for so there's the short I just outlined in the previous portion of this video
wrote all that down held for the gap opening after reopen at six o'clock and there is the
close of the trade right there nice little dandy four thousand nine hundred twenty dollars fixes the
little pinch I took on the one trade earlier in the day and the one scratch was nothing it was
covering costs okay and again there's the business there that's the entry and that's the exit and
there's no commission costs on the one above that so you can see that it was not a trade
hope you found this insightful until talk to you on Thursday be safe